the first meeting of
ten between the astros and the a's and
they're gonna be taking on the big
righty chris bassett making his third
start of the season has been throwing
the ball extremely well in this rotation
here threw the ball very well last time
out
against the seattle mariners we talked
about it in the open five and two thirds
one run baseball
and here is alex bregman pregnant at 235
he's got three home runs nine rvis four
doubles 12 hits and 51 at bats
murphy sets up inside the pitch if
bregman bounces it up the middle to his
left the shortstop simeon has it throws
to first
and the inning is over cranky on the
mound for the astros no wins or losses
of five era in two starts nine innings
seven hits two walks six strikeouts
league batting 212
against granky after iraqi first start
of the year against the mariners was
much better saturday in anaheim
four home runs and 10 rbis now for matt
olson
swing and a miss grenke a pop up and a
couple of strikeouts and a one two three
start to this one for zach
well dallas this made us laugh this was
at grand cube before the game was
sitting
in the stands after his first inning
award back to the stage
i mean is that not ideal you've got the
security guard there
you got yourself a doorman i mean just
get comfy
chris davis four hits in his last six at
bats
[Applause]
shallow center straw hustling in can't
get it it pops up over his head
davis is gonna try for second and he's
gonna make it so that's the first hit
for the a's it's a two out double and
here's grossman
a little q shot and the gold glover zach
grinky makes the play easily for the
final out of the inning little flair
double one man left on base we're
scoreless through two
he's a one out base runner first walk
issued by bassett back to the top of the
order for kyle tucker
tucker to center field straight away
sending lauriano back he's at the track
and watch it off the wall
maldonado had to hold up and he's now
being waved around
and he'll get there and score the first
run of the game for the astros it's one
nothing
on a double by kyle tucker off the wall
taking that pitch middle away the two
seam running away from him
he actually did a very good job of
bringing his hands in and tearing that
ball the other way
here's josh redick who was called out on
strikes his first time up
reddick sends one into left field coming
on is grossman and he puts it away and
that'll do it for the astros we're
through three and a half
one nothing houston one nothing houston
bottom of the fourth
matt standing in chapman popped up to
the second baseman his first time
here's the 1-1 swung on hit in the air
to right center field straw on his way
going back toward the wall and he'll
jump at the wall it's in play
back to radical fired in by the time he
does chapman
stands at second base with a double
stayed through that pitch gets his
second two base hit of the year
time run at scoring position with one
out here's the three one
swung on grounded right back to him
actually caught in the air
and granny throws back behind the runner
and doubles off chapman that's why he's
won the gold glove
a liner that was going back up the
middle and found the mitt and the inning
is over we're through four
so grossman hit by a pitch and murphy
coming up one out one on bottom of the
fifth one nothing
astros that's going to get through into
center field the base hit
grossman's going to try for third here
comes straw's throw it's cut off for the
a's at first and third with one out
marcus steps up pop out in the first
single in the third grossman at third
murphy had second kemp at first
so you don't always get a lot of
opportunities against grinke and when
you do have one
you really really have to cash in three
two
and that is grounded right out correa
down to one knee flips it to second for
one altuve on the first and that's an
ending ending six four three double play
oakland a's load them up with one out
and do not score
zach crank he's been hanging out with
the cutouts tonight at the oakland
coliseum
far so good he and chris bassett have
hooked into a good little pitchers duel
here
the fish delariano is a line drive in
the center sinking and that's going to
be a base hit
and straw falls down it rolls behind him
and goes all the way to the wall
larianno's streaking to second he's
around second going to third they're
going to put up the stop sign
and ramon will hold it third with a
triple mile straw
came in on a sinking lie drive put on
the brakes but his feet went out from
under him
[Applause]
fly ball locked it down the left field
line playable for correa
zach cranky a magician tonight works
around a runner on third and
nobody out that guy knows how to pitch
he deserves a big hand from his manager
that was a great outing
he's going to go back to his seat you go
out you deal for
seven seven shut go hang out with some
cardboard cutout friends of mine
here comes robbie grossman with oakland
down one to nothing
best ball belted deep right center field
by grossman
back on it as reddick at the wall tie
game
an ambush by robbie grossman on josh
james turns around 96
and ties the game at one so here's
bregman
about slow to the right side kev he's
got it and his throw to first and
they just get brickman
nice play by tony can't be a long ways
to go just
watch his knees here he'll spin pivot
and then pop up
now it's three and one with bregman
waiting in the indexer
chapman's got it he gets up his throw in
time
that chapman saves the ball game for the
athletics
with a diving play to his left well now
it's the ultimate drama with the bases
loaded two outs tie game eleventh inning
swinging a miss agnoli for radies has
done it again
two shutout innings working out of a
first and third
no out jam it's the top of the 13th
and it's a 1-1 game bregman into right
center field that ball is going to be
down and go all the way to the wall
stump scores the go-ahead run alex
bregman keeps us on base streak alive
the astros lead
2-1 in the 13th so the
go-ahead run put on first base and
they'll go after
the young catcher austin allen base hit
left center field
on an 0-2 pitch allen comes through so
chapman scores going to third grossman
he's safe
and it's tied at two go ahead run put on
first base and they'll go after
the young catcher austin allen base hit
left center field
on an 02 pitch allen comes through so
chapman scores going to third grossman
he's safe
and it's tied at two so marcus simeon
steps up
driven to right center is anybody gonna
get it no they're not and the a's are
gonna win the game
marcus simeon comes through in the first
pitch drives under the wall in right
center
and the athletics in an unbelievable
ball game tonight
13 innings they defeat the houston
astros by a final score of three
to two